the sonification project essentially is
just a way that turns NASA data into
sound using our ears to hear instead of
just our eyes to see it it actually
started as a project because during the
pandemic I really wanted to be able to
keep working with my community members
and colleagues who are blind or low
vision and our previous 3D printing
program just became very challenging
during the pandemic you couldn't be in
the same room with someone never mind
share a 3D print so Matt I got an idea
for her I'm listening I'm always they
started out with 3D printing right so
that's your sense of touch so then you
went to auditory data yep and I'm
thinking why not go to taste I stopped
there like since I've drawn a lot no no
no we could taste the data I feel like
the taste and the smells might be scary
like sulfur iron yes rotten eggs no
thank you oh my gosh this is the next
thing no I think we're good
thank you